[Musique]
irè Chagot propose voyage sans passeport
cette émission est réalisée avec le
concours de Jean géin et de Solange
péter son Guy Solignac montagevon
illustration sonore de Nice
[Musique]
Glazer nous sommes au bord du lac
Victoria en Afrique orientale anglaise à
l'aéroport d'antibé très
exactement nous nous préparons à
survoler le canal de Mozambique canal
qui sépare l'Afrique de menutias ou
Madagascar qui sépare la côte sud-est de
l'Afrique pour être
[Musique]
précise dernier préparatif avant le
[Applaudissements]
départ
[Musique]
nous voilà parti ce canal est un bras de
mer fermé du côté nord par les îes Comor
et par des écueils mais bien sûr nous le
survolons alors cela a peu d'importance
mais je vous le disais parce que si vous
aviez l'intention d'aller faire du canoé
là-bas vous risqueriez fortement un
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pépin
Madagascar vous nignorez pas j'en suis
sûr est une grande île française de
l'océan Indien elle fut découverte en
1500 par le Portugais Diego
Diaz sa superficie est de
592350 km car ce qui l'a fait plus
grande que la France car cette dernière
si j'ai bonne mémoire a une superficie
de
km² pour l'instant nous sommes à 100 km
de tananaarive autrement dit de la
capitale à 100 km au sud où se trouve
une région de haut plateau très sec et
un petit peu plus bas ici on cultive le
riz qui est un des aliments des
indigènes avec le manioc le maïs les
poiss de cap et les
arachides
bien vous le devinez tous ces gens se
rendent au marché
local car là aussi il y a un
March
charm
sourire au fond assez peu de
chos
[Musique]
fruits
si vous aimz ce que je ne sauris vous
reprocher du reste la viande genre filet
bien tendre n'allz pas là-bas le bétail
est abattu dans la nuit et livré à la
consommation le lendemain évidemment
elle est un peu dure mais ils peuvent
l'éviter puisquil n'existe aucune
installation
frigorifique la légende veut que cette
foule grouillante soit les descendants
des nains des kimos qui habitèrent
primitivement l'île je dis la légende
car en vérité quand les Malais
débarquèrent ils trouvèrent des noirs
sur quelques point des Arabes et les
juifs et les hindou avaient laissé
quelques trac de leur
sang les Européens vinrent compliquer le
mélange et tout cela donna les
Malgaches
ils vivent d'agriculture d'élevage leur
vie apparaît primitive et cependant
c'est un des peuples noirs les plus
évolués ils ont bien que vous ne le
voyez pas sur ces images des mairies des
églises leurs cases sont à deux étages
ils dorment au second étage et le soir
ils enlèvent l'échelle qui les y conduit
ce qui fait qu'ils sont parfaitement
chez
eux
play
voussi une vision
coutumière c'est la récolte du riz c'est
une chose très
importante
[Musique]
on le fait en
famille
[Musique]
Zuma Zuma c'est le marché le marché
Tanan arrive il a lieu tous les
vendredis autrement dit demain et bien
demain il y aura ça
[Musique]
à les coiffures de beauté locales sont
faites bien sû de cheveux crépus et très
tiré en arrière c'est ce qu'elles
appellent un petit
[Musique]
gen les toits de T ondulés commenc à
remplacer parci par là ce
[Musique]
ch
et adieu à Madagascar en passant par le
[Musique]
Kilimanjaro
est-ce le Mawenzi ou le cratère Kibo
voulez-vous me le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dire
[Musique]